♪ (intro music) ♪
Being able to compose widgets together
is one of Flutter's
most powerful features.
But how can you specify
how a child should be laid out
or positioned inside its parent?
For example, if you have
a Container widget,
how do you choose where a Text widget
might show up inside it?
The simplest case is to center it
using the Center widget.
But what if you want to place it
in the bottom right, for example?
Here's where the Align widget
comes in handy.
Align will let you place widgets
in a defined area of its parent widget,
such as the bottomRight,
or topLeft, or centerRight--
wherever you fancy.
You can also specify the alignment values
where -1 to 1 are the ranges
for both left to right and top to bottom.
This lets you precisely lay out
your child widget within its parent.
You can also use Align
to position widgets in a stack.
For more info on Align,
head on over to flutter.io
♪ (music) ♪